after mamma mia two did cher
get the mamma mia tattoo that the rest
of you got
no no this ages ago this was mamma mia
one
oh okay she bought me a two and mamia
won
my my girlfriends ashley and rachel
one of them is liverpudlian and the
other one is scottish
and they we just minge was a thing minge
became
beautiful i mean i'm mingy on instagram
like minge do you know how many texts i
got for my birthday today that say happy
birthday minge like that's what my
friends taught me
and that's called each other and so
therefore
minge and we got that tattoo god years
ago oh my god years ago
and people made fun of me for it i can't
remember
what it's not i'm not talking about a
vagina anymore it's a it's a term of
endearment
i understand vaginas but it's not
a vagina on my foot it's my name yeah
[Music]